se nos pide utilizar los menús
desplegables para formar una ecuación
lineal que no tenga soluciones o sea una
ecuación lineal que no importa cómo la
manipulemos al final lo que tengamos a
la izquierda no sea igual a lo que
tengamos a la derecha y vamos a ver qué
opciones nos dan primero debemos escoger
un coeficiente para el término de x y
luego debemos escoger la constante si
aquí ponemos 7x tendremos 7x en los dos
lados de la ecuación y aquí del lado
izquierdo tenemos 7 x 9 si escogemos una
constante diferente a menos 9 osea si
escogemos este 7 aquí no vamos a tener
ninguna solución y ustedes se podrían
preguntar oye cómo se te ocurrió eso
vamos a pensar tenemos 7x aquí del lado
izquierdo y 7x del lado derecho
si queremos resolverlo algebraica mente
restamos 7x de los dos lados y anulamos
estos términos quitamos 7x de los dos
lados y todo lo que nos queda es un 9
negativo igual a 7 lo cual no es posible
para ningún valor
x que escojamos otra forma de pensar en
esto es decir bueno aquí tengo un 7 x
cualquier número y le restamos 9 y de
este lado tengo 7 x ese número y en
lugar de restar el 9 le sumamos 7
entonces no existe ningún valor de x
para el que esto sea verdadero vamos a
checar nuestra respuesta